émotionnelle sur le ratio le sectarisme
de la majorité d'entre elles les amènent
à des interprétations qui exclut toute
pensée ou comportements n'allant pas
dans leur sens et leur condition
n'hésitant pas à tordre les faits et à
utiliser tous les moyens pour imposer
leur vérité
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
le résultat d'un toit peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
oubliez pas de réagir sur le télégramme
verte et france vous pouvez prendre
évidemment part au débat interpeller nos
invités au sommaire de ce lundi 25
octobre les sondages sur la
présidentielle son fils à bannir le
journal ouest france a en tout cas
décidé de ne peut publier ses études
d'opinion pour le rédacteur en chef du
quotidien ça n'apporte rien ces sondages
détourne même de l'essentiel à savoir
les débats de fond qui intéresse les
français alors faut-il se passer des
sondages on en débat dans quelques
instants et on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme daté
france
la situation au soudan qui se tend trois
personnes tuées et 80 blessées cet après
midi par des tirs de l'armée à khartoum
lors de manifestations dénonçant un coup
d'état les autorités de transition
plutôt été dissoute par le général abdel
fattah al borhane le chef du
gouvernement et la plupart des ministres
sont aux mains d'hommes armés dans un
lieu inconnu l'état d'urgence a été
décrété par les militaires alors comment
expliquer ce foutu dénoncée par la
communauté internationale pourquoi le
pays est-il aussi instable analyse en
deuxième partie d'émission
cet assassinat dit beaucoup de choses
sur la place des femmes et de la
sexualité dans les citer cette phrase
est signée de l'avocate de la famille de
shannan à cette jeune fille victime d'un
viol collectif poignardé et brûlé vive
il y a deux ans jour pour jour à créteil
ce soir dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français nous irons à la
rencontre de l'entourage de
l'adolescente de 15 ans qui demande que
justice soit faite témoignage à suivre à
21h
[Musique]
qui dit campagne électorale dit
forcément on s'en rend compte sondages à
tout va à six mois de la présidentielle
le quotidien ouest france a donc décidé
de ne plus rien y est relayé ses
intentions de vote un geste fort est
plutôt rare dans les médias pour le
rédacteur en chef ces sondages détourne
de l'essentiel des beats khalifa
environ 630 mille exemplaires vendus par
jour ouest france est cette année une
nouvelle fois le quotidien le plus vendu
au sein de l'hexagone et pourtant le
rédacteur en chef du journal a pris
cette décision pour le moins étonnante
il ne publiera aucun sondage avant les
présidentielles s'il considère à les
sondeurs comme des professionnels
françois-xavier lefranc n'acceptent plus
cette avalanche d'intentions de vote qui
tombe sur les citoyens mais il refuse
surtout d'alimenter les débats
médiatiques écouter ouest france ne
participera pas à la grande manif ne
réalisera aucun sondage politique avant
la présidentielle et évitera de perdre
du temps à commenter ceux des autres
nous nous consacrerons reportage à l'anc
est au plus près de celles et ceux qui
ont des choses à dire une prise de
position qui s'explique également par la
montée en puissance des partis extrêmes
françois-xavier lefranc souhaiterait
davantage de reportages sur le terrain
pour aller à la rencontre des français
beaucoup plus révélateur pour lui que
ces sondages il ajoute que ce recours
systématique évitez également de se
pencher sérieusement sur les programmes
des candidats en tout cas ce risque
éditorial pris par ouest-france présage
une élection présidentielle plus que
jamais indécise et alors les sondages
commandés publié en pleine campagne
présidentielle sont ils de trop quel
impact peuvent avoir ses intentions de
vote faut-il s'en passer on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme verte
france elles ont déjà été nombreuses un
autre face à face s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
et avec nous pourrons parler d'eux ni de
mon pions éditorialiste politique
bonsoir denis demonpion merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau à vos côtés
thomas gauvin ce qui est membre du
collectif droite pour la france vous
vous présentez comme la droite qui n'est
pas macron compatible c'est important de
le préciser bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous alors ne plus commander ni commenté
d'ailleurs des sondages c'est une
décision qui fait évidemment beaucoup
parlé réagir à nos téléspectateurs sur
le conte télégramme daté france on
commence par regarder l'un des messages
un gie nous qui nous écrit tout
simplement ça c'est en une phrase il
oriente surtout les gens indécis voici
pour le mon premier commentaire du soir
denis demonpion des sondages qui
servirait à rien qui orienterait en plus
les légendes et si c'est juste à ça que
ça sert les sondages mais les sondages
se fait partie du jeu mais je pense pas
que ça ait un effet réel au moment du
vote puisque beaucoup de gens se
détermine une fois dans l'isoloir
souvent donc des sondages sont plus fait
pour les médias en réalité par les
journalistes et videmment qui en joue
pourquoi parce que les candidats n'ont
pas tous les jours une chose nouvelle à
annoncer même si c'est un peu la grande
braderie en ce moment à six mois des
élections et est donc voilà il commande
des sondages d'ailleurs un des experts
en la matière ça a été nicolas sarkozy
donc c'est présente quand il était
président de la république pour un oui
pour un an
il demande un sondage pour indexer un
peu son comportement
y compris d'ailleurs
pour ces affaires de coeur puisque on se
souvient que après le départ de cécilia
il avait commandé des sondages pour voir
si les français jugeraient d'un bon oeil
qu'il se remarie alors qu'il était à 10
et enfin moyer c'est ils se font plus
plaisir au fond des hommes politiques
avec ces sondages qu'autre chose mais ce
qui est intéressant dans le cas de ouest
france c'est que il faut le rappeler
c'est quand même le quotidien qui a le
plus gros tirage en france tous les
jours et ce n'est pas rien qu'un journal
comme celui ci décide à six mois des
élections de faire l'impasse totale sur
la fabrique de l'information d'une
certaine manière on va en parler
justement sur ses conséquences avec vous
parce que évidemment c'est extrêmement
intéressant
tommaso ski sur cette décision de ouest
france et sur l'utilité des sondages
vous allez regretter je vous allez
arrêter de lire moi de france parce que
ça va être moins intéressants ou au
contraire vous trouvez que c'est une
décision avec beaucoup de panache
finalement il fallait avoir le courage
de la prendre et elle est fort utile
alors je dirais que la recette dans
cette campagne il ya un peu la
jurisprudence zemmour sur un peu tout
donc c'est assez intéressant sérier les
origines zemmour sur le csa il y avait
là claude zemmour pour la primaire des
républicains alors maintenant ouest
france parce que ces débours parce qu'il
faut quand même a trait à ces honnêtes
dire balance ça pourrait des zemmour le
grand fasciste donc on va arrêter les
sondages dont je trouve qu'ils sont pas
très à leur place là dessus pour
évidemment trouver de manière un peu
tortueuses un truc pu dire finalement
non après pour votre question de tout à
l'heure et s permettre de répondre oui
et les sondages on peuvent avoir un
effet mais non il ne crée pas les
candidats ou il ya
le sondage qui voulait qu'on parle juste
des sondages d'intentions de vote parce
qu'après il ya plein de sondage qui
peuvent être faits sur l'opinion etc
mais effectivement il peut arriver à un
moment que lorsque vous devez déterminer
votre choix vous avez notamment dans une
présidentielle ou dans l'autre sa
constance envie de voter pour un
candidat qui peut accéder au second tour
donc pour le vote utile effectivement le
jeudi ben alors si j'ai un candidat qui
a 3 % et l'autre qui peut-être peut se
qualifier gp est plutôt voter pour celui
là donc ça peut avoir effectivement un
effet sauf qu on n'en est pas là et
aujourd'hui de toute façon quand on dit
que les sondages vont si vous voulez
inventer des choses là où s france ils
sont quand même un petit peu de mauvaise
foi je dirais là dessus c'est que c'est
pas les sondages qui font vendre le
livre d'eric zemmour c'est pas les
sondages qui remplissent les salles et
c'est donc après sur un autre sujet si
ouest france veut dire il n'ya pas que
les sondages et il ya des débats de fond
je suis d'accord mais dans ce cas là
j'ai envie de renvoyer la balle à
l'ensemble des médias c'est à dire que
moi je suis à fond pour du débat les
arguments et ce soit ça qui convainque
les personnes bas il n'y a pas que
ouest-france en quand ce que couvre la
compagne avant mais pour n'importe
quelle élection on voit quand même qu'il
ya des grands débats qui sont organisées
le soir du premier tour moi je rêve d'un
pays où ce soit avant le premier tour td
grande soirée électorale donc ouest
france c'est pas leur faute donc si ils
se servent de ça pour faire vraiment
débat de fond sur les propositions très
bien donc on va les juger
sinon ce qu'ils vont faire denis
demonpion évidemment cette question
zemmour faux procès de la part de thomas
sophos qui sait voilà c'est parce qu'il
ya cette ce spectre zemmour qui ne plaît
pas à tout le monde que soudain
le spectre zemmour pour qui il se trouve
qu eric zemmour
s'est pas lancé en campagne mais a
commencé à
comment dirais-je exposer ses points de
vue ce qui pourrait être un programme
pour le lancement de son livre la france
n'a pas dit son dernier mot alors je
rappelle quand même que il est fréquent
pour les hommes politiques de faire un
livre ça a été le cas d'arnaud
montebourg ça a été le cas de nombreux
valérie pécresse pour les pianos jacques
chirac à l'époque jacques chirac tous
l'ont fait d'aider des livres un peu
programmatique emmanuel macron lui-même
avec révolution c'était avant même qu'il
ne se déclare avec publier ce livre il
se trouve qu eric zemmour est un peu
singulier dans le paysage pourquoi parce
que son précédent livre le suicide
français avait eu déjà une audience
extraordinaire puisque il avait vendu
plus de 500000 exemplaires ce qui n'est
pas rien quand on sait qu'un livre en
moyenne savant 10000 quinze mille copies
quand françois hollande arrivent à 60
milles c'est presqu'un record voyez
c'est quand même voilà ça dit quelque
chose il remet ça aujourd'hui parce que
en effet avec le suicide français il
était apparu pour un déclinistes vous
savez à la mode il n'était pas le
premier d'ailleurs à
tabler sur le déclin de la france est
aujourd'hui ces voix là on se retrousse
les manches on se ressaisit et il
distille un petit peu ce que contient
son livre d'une certaine manière alors
la question évidemment ce qui était un
secret de polichinelle sera utile ou pas
candidat évidemment qu'il le sera
aujourd'hui c'est une question lui même
le dit d'ailleurs ou son entourage c'est
une question de date il est
vraisemblable que ce sera au tour du du
15 novembre certains mêmes disent que ça
pourrait être le 11 novembre
et donc
alors que eric zemmour
décoiffe c'est certain pourquoi parce
que il ya les sondages ont beaucoup joué
sur cette rivalité jeté au sol va droit
pourquoi sonder les candidats par encore
déclaré je vous invite à regarder encore
cette réaction celle de david à
ça inspire de téléspectateurs cette
question des sondages parce qu'il a
toujours sous jacent cette question des
manipulations les sondages ne sont pas
neutres vous n'avez qu'à répondre à l'un
d'eux et vous comprendrez comment s'est
orientée tous les candidats potentiels
ne sont pas pris en compte et des
questions sont verrouillées et orientez
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic
c'est vrai que tous les candidats ne
sont pas forcément sondés donc il ya une
spéculation là en dessous attendez c'est
pas parce que c'est pas mal d'arguments
qui revient extrêmement souvent on l'a
vu cet après midi dans ce message un
sérieux c'est pas parce qu'un sondage
est perfectible et qui peut nous être
adressée il ya plein de problèmes avec
les sondages c'est pas pour ça que c'est
une manipulation enfin soit un petit peu
moi je trouve que je trouve ça boureux
sur les sondages c'est quand même
finalement les républicains qui se
prennent leur boomerang dans la tête
dont je fais partie mais j'ai aussi fait
partie de ceux qui disaient il ne faut
pas s'appuyer sur les sondages pour
désigner notre candidat c'était quand
même la méthode jacob
et il faut faire une primaire ouverte y
compris à tous ceux qui pourraient se
présenter y compris eric zemmour denis
payre ou ou qui siègent donc ils ont
tenté parce qu'en fait il voulait
imposer à son de candidats notamment
xavier bertrand dire en effet que ce
soit le plus mieux placé dans les
sondages c'est quand même inédit dans
l'histoire de la vème république un
parti disent devoir regarder les
sondages pour choisir notre candidat
alors qu'il suffit de faire voter les
personnes m'ont finalement il ya un
congrès donc maintenant il se retrouve
dans un boomerang puisque c'est vrai que
zoom moore qui est en tête des sondages
donc effectivement là ils sont un petit
peu mal à l'aise mais c'est un peu leur
faute mais donc les sondages pour moi
nous manipule rien les candidats s'en
servent en axe de communication et
chacun s'en sert zemmour s'en sert pour
dire ce second tour bertrand dit c'est
moi qui peut gagner après les électeurs
j'ai envie de dire pour moi comme je
l'aï dit au début à part dans la
dernière ligne droite pour voter pour un
vote utile mais il est déjà les
intentions de vote il ya une partie des
gens qui ceux qui sont dans les eaux
loir qui décide dans l'isoloir mais
d'autres sont déjà décidés à bord il
peut y avoir un petit effet mais vous
ferez jamais passé une personne qui a 2
% de votes entre guillemets réel aux
sondages à 25% c'est pas vrai ça joue à
la marche en tout cas le rédacteur en
chef du web france a écrit dans sa
tribune qu'il ne veut pas alimenter les
débats médiatiques il va même plus loin
lecteurs l'interpeller sur twitter
regarder ce qu'il répond à françois
xavier
je n'ai pas parlé de complot mais de
manipulation ce qui n'est pas la même
chose ce n'est pas les sondeurs que je
mets en cause ce sont des gens sérieux
mais la manipulation des sondages
commenté tordu martelé est repris en
boucle sans aucun recul et c'est grave
françois-xavier le franc c'est vrai que
les grandes chaînes de télé par beaucoup
d'eric zemmour regardez encore si vous
regardez les chaînes info ce matin débat
sur le permis à points oui mais faisait
il faut pas se tromper parce que il se
trouve que eric zemmour
a une popularité et ont peut-être contre
tout contre eric zemmour mais les faits
sont là et ces candidats sortis de nulle
part vous savez ça renvoie un peu à
cause du ch déjà quand coluche c'était
n'ont pas présenté mais avait laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait être candidat il
y avait eu tout de suite dé son âge et
il était arrivé à 11 12 13 % de
popularité des gens qui vraiment dès
demain était prête à voter pour lui eric
zemmour il se trouve que quand il a fait
son débat avec jean luc mélenchon il a
quand même ramassé un score
extraordinaire de près de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs alors que sur une autre
chaîne
darmanin l'intérieur ont tout de suite
plafonné à 1 est mignon ça dit quelque
chose d'un phénomène et il faut pas
perdre de vue que ce soit les chaînes de
télévision ou les jours nous ils les ont
quand même un intérêt c'est de vendre
certains leurs pages de publicité et les
journaux du papier moi j'ai le souvenir
qu'en 2007 quand il ya eu vous savez le
lancement de la campagne ségolène royal
nicolas sarkozy bond à 5 6 mois ils
étaient au coude à coude tout à coup il
ya un sondage qui faisait passer l'une
devant l'autre et puis après nicolas
sarkozy a pris le leadership bon et
2 de crainte que les comment dirais-je
acheteurs de journaux ou télé
spectateurs s'ennuient
ils ont lancé ils étaient quelques-uns à
oeuvrer pour le troisième homme qui a
été françois bayrou et françois bayrou a
fait la une de tous les journaux il a
été invité dans toutes les émissions etc
etc et finalement
les électeurs se sont pris au jeu et
puisque dans les sondages il arrivait
quand même à 17% il l'a fait d'ailleurs
un très très bon score mais donc le
pouvoir quand même des dégâts maintenant
on met le cas de deux noms pourquoi
parce que françois bayrou quand il est
arrivé il avait aussi un programme
quand même très clair et c'est très
important ça quand ouest-france dit nous
on va plus traiter le chômage il faut
espérer qu'ils vont en effet faire un
travail de journaliste c'est à dire se
pencher sur le programme des candidats
ce que ça peut changer ou apporter comme
bien-être aux français ou pas c'est ça
les questions qui se posent le reste
soit c'est du vent d'ailleurs on sait
que des sondages se sont beaucoup de
tromper on l'a vu en 94 avec balladur a
dit systématique
dessus justement vous voyez vous faites
là un rôle ans je peux dire la
transition la relation parce que c'est
aussi un débat si vous voulez les
sondages ça fait partie de la météo ça
fait chacun rebondi dessus que je veux
dire il ya eu le
mérite sondages se trompent toujours
donc de toute façon à mon neveu oui la
météo à plus de 4 jours vous savez on
peut pas d'après
et donc élections à plus de six mois à
dire jacques chirac il était très bas
dans les sondages il a continué il a
fait son livre est il arrivé il arrive
au deuxième tour donc c'est des
personnes qui sont derrière mais ça veut
pas dire que en juillet 94 sondages
étaient faux les choses ont changé donc
c'est un instantané les gens jouent avec
voilà effectivement ouest france si ils
font du contenu des choses très
intéressantes
ce serait bien et j'espère qu'ils se
contenteront pas de crier au fascisme
se sont quand même bien trompé mais on a
la pression on a comme l'impression que
comme le thermomètre affiche pas la
bonne température tout d'un coup on a
envie de le casser c'est à dire que pour
d'autres élections il aura attendu que
ce soit là dessus et je pense qu'en plus
c'est complètement vain que sondages ou
pas il ya et non de zemmour il ratait
d'autres on va voir ce qui va se passer
dans la campagne aujourd'hui l'oms et
mouret la tuque à ce thermomètre ou pas
et ouest-france bas c'est très bien si
il alimenta campagne sur les vraies
attentes des français permis de conduire
en sécurité ou autre 1 un dernier petit
un petit message pour la route on arrive
à la fin de ce débat les sondages existe
t'il uniquement pour influencer les
canard sans tête qui se cherche un
sauveur évidemment que les sondages sont
bidon nous dit sophie macro avec ses 3 %
les jeunes allaient 25 pensant aux
présidentielles lol construit tel déni
des mangas mais c'est vrai que c'est
assez paradoxal parce que on crédite
emmanuel macron d'un score phénoménal
bon attention devos 25% mais sa
popularité serait supérieure à 40% bon
déjà il faut regarder quel média mairie
sollicite ces sondages c'est très
important parce que c'est ce que disait
un set vais d'ailleurs de la proximité
de ces instituts de sondage et de ces
médias avec le président de la
république et ce qui est quand même
curieux si on regarde les résultats
c'est que malgré cette
soi-disant popularité et bien emmanuel
macron et son parti n'ont pas réussi à
faire de percer lie aux municipales ni
aux régionales donc ça pose un problème
quand même il ya quand même là une
espèce de fossé entre les deux alors
c'est vrai que l'élection présidentielle
c'est d'un autre type puisque c'est la
rencontre entre un ou une candidate
candidats candidates et les électeurs
donc c'est un un autre jeu mais il faut
quand même
rappeler que
l'abstention est très importante en
france y compris à l'élection
présidentielle à la dernière élection
qui a vu emmanuel macron
élus et bien il y avait quand même
autant d'abstentionnistes et deux
bulletins blancs quand on a eu marine le
pen ce qu'il en dit long sur le malaise
dans ce pays merci en tout cas à tous
les deux tommaso vos skis denis
demonpion un signal à la sortie de votre
nouvel ouvrage politique dr denis
demonpion docteur la mort le légiste qui
a autopsié erignac dit cette histoire
inédite chez robert laffont merci à vous
deux d'avoir essayé en direct avec nous
et que l'on donne du crédit ou pas aux
sondages emmanuel macron est lui
toujours favori en tout cas dans les
intentions de vote le président sortant
n'a pas encore déclaré sa candidature à
la présidentielle il n'en reste pas
moins qu'ils sillonnent les villes là
pour aller à la rencontre des français
aujourd'hui le chef d'état s'est rendue
à saint-etienne et montbrison dans la
loire pour prendre un bain de foule mais
il a aussi été accueillie par une
centaine de manifestants et les
syndicats mécontents de sa politique
pouvoir d'achat hausse du prix du
carburant de nombreux sujets ont été
abordés au cours de la prise de parole
partout où il se déplacera je pense
qu'il aura comme ça des comités
d'accueil c'est plus un président c'est
un candidat
est ce qu'en dit là il ya un bilan très
mauvais très très mauvais notamment en
matière de pouvoir d'achat je rappelle
que le 5 octobre on est déjà des
dizaines de milliers en grève en
manifestations dans la rue pour dénoncer
la situation faite aux salariés tout a
augmenté et sauf que et bien les
salaires n'ont pas les salaires et les
retraites et les minima sociaux n'ont
pas suivi pour autant
il y en a qui ont bien profité de la
crise puisque les entreprises du cac 40
ont fait des profits comme jamais sur le
premier semestre ces 57 milliards
d'euros de dividendes ont été versés aux
actionnaires donc de l'argent et on en
est ce que réclame la cgt s'est
effectivement qu'ils soient répartis
d'une autre manière et c'est ça que nous
voulons faire entendre auprès de la
république aujourd'hui à mais il est
complètement catastrophique le bilan de
macron
ccc juste le rouleau le rouleau
compresseur social qui continue
d'avancer et
voilà nous on essaie d'y mettre un frein
quoi en se rassemblant et en se
mobilisant message que l'on souhaiterait
faire passer c'est celui du manque de
moyens
nos écoles et
de moyens qui est connu
qui est qui s'amplifie d'année en année
qui commence à devenir vraiment très
problématique pour les conditions
d'apprentissage de nos élèves
un point à présent sur le front de la
lutte anti copies dans le monde certains
pays ont décidé de re confiné pour
éviter la saturation des hôpitaux c'est
le cas de la capitale russe où un
confinement partielle de quatre mois est
entré en vigueur aujourd'hui sont
concernés notamment les plus de 60 ans
moscou qui fait face à la recrudescence
des contaminations couple est parent
taux de vaccination faible les
explications de notre correspondant au
berghof man
presque 38 mille nouveaux cas de
couronnes au virus en russie ces
dernières 24 heures le pays égale son
record du nombre de contaminations
quotidienne quant aux décès leurs
nouveaux continuent de dépasser lumier
par jour le chiffre annoncé de 1069
victimes du coc u19 ce jour au ministère
russe de la santé oms nassian que ce
taux de mortalité
particulièrement élevé est dû aux
variants delta le risque de décès ayant
augmenté de 2,3 fois et ce alors que le
pic des contaminations des décès n'a pas
encore été atteint je vous propose
d'écouter à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
aucune raison de penser que le taux
d'incidence du coc vie 19 en russie a
atteint un sommet le niveau de
couverture vaccinale contre la nouvelle
infection à coronavirus est un facteur
clé de l'incidence du coc vite 19
en outre l'augmentation de cette
incidence est également due aux variant
du virus aujourd'hui nous constatons la
dominance du variant delta dussart skov
2 qui est plus contagieux et une
photogénie site est plus élevé c'est à
dire qu'ils se développent plus
rapidement et provoque des formes plus
grave de la maladie et donc associée à
un risque accru d'hospitalisations et de
décès sur fond de flambée des chiffres
épidémique vladimir poutine s'est
adressé ce matin aux responsables
régionaux en recommandant une série de
mesures restrictives qui doivent
s'ajouter à la période chômée afin de
contrer la propagation du virus dont le
rck ont finalement pour les personnes de
plus de 60 ans qui ne sont pas vaccinés
au l'interdiction pour les bars et les
restaurants d'accueillir du public entre
23 heures et 6 heures du matin écoutez
vous l'a dit poutine a recommandé aux
régions de donner aux employés deux
jours de congés payés pour se faire
vacciner
d'interdire les spectacles et
divertissements et de limiter la
fourniture de services de restauration
le soir et la nuit d'interdire pendant
la nuit les divertissements et le
fonctionnement des restaurants de faire
passer les salariés de plus de 60 ans et
ceux qui souffrent de maladies
chroniques en télétravail pour quatre
semaines
d'assurer que les personnes non
vaccinées de plus de 60 ans respecte le
régime de confinement de ne laisser
entrer dans certains établissements que
les personnes possédant un certificat de
vaccination ou attestant qu'ils sont
rétablis de la maladie y compris via un
qr code pour rappel le président russe
la dîmière poutine instaurer une période
chômée partout en russie du 30 octobre
au 7 novembre les régions où la
situation épidémiologique et plus graves
peuvent atteindre cette période pour le
dire est qu'elle estime nécessaires
seraient de nouveau confinement chine
également ce provinces du nord du pays
sont concernés pas d'explosion du nombre
de cas mais pékin implique une politique
de tolérance zéro à l'encontre du kobe
19 la chine qui redouble de vigilance à
la poche des jo d'hiver grâce d'aia
des files d'attentes interminables pour
se faire dépister à pékin depuis
quelques semaines le gouvernement
chinois s'emploie à prévenir tout risque
de transmission du virus plus d'une
centaine de cas ont été recensés la
semaine dernière à l'échelle du pays 39
ce dimanche des chiffres qui peuvent
sembler dérisoires mais qui inquiète les
autorités u10 on s'attend à ce que le
nombre de cas découverts dans les
prochains jours continue d'augmenter
au fur et à mesure que le dépistage des
groupes à risque se poursuit
la portée de l'épidémie pourrait encore
s'étendre
des contaminations en variant delta qui
pour le gouvernement chinois serait dû
au déplacement d'un groupe de touristes
pour l'heure onze provinces du pays sont
concernés nous allons faire du porte à
porte pour nous assurer que tout le
monde connaît les règles
de plus notre comptes publics et notre
groupe ou chat ont également envoyer des
notifications quotidiennement pour
s'assurer que leurs besoins quotidiens
comme l'achat d'électricité et d'eau
cette reprise en compte
le gouvernement chinois a imposé des
campagnes massives de dépistage dans les
régions concernées et des fermetures
d'établissements et de services ciblés
comme les bus ou des taxis et notamment
dans la ville de laon joe hogan zoom et
du côté de hejin en mongolie intérieure
trente cinq mille personnes se sont vu
imposer un confinement de deux semaines
autre mesure prise les trente mille
coureurs qui devait participer au
marathon de pékin dimanche prochain ont
vu leur course annulée par mesure de
prévention la semaine dernière c'est à
one la ville où avait été identifié le
coronavirus pour la première fois qu'un
autre marathon a dû être annulé pour le
même motif près de 100 jours avant les
jeux olympiques d'hiver la chine est
plus que jamais sur le qui-vive dimanche
à pékin une suspension des voyages en
ter provinciaux nous nécessaire a été
mise en place tolérance zéro pour le
kobe de 19 telle est la politique des
autorités chinoises
le débat sur le port d'armes aux états
unis ressurgit quatre jours après
l'accident sur un plateau de cinéma au
nouveau au nouveau-mexique lecteurs alec
baldwin a été l'auteur d'un tir mortel
larmes étaient pourtant censés être
chargé de balles à blanc une pétition
est actuellement en ligne pour demander
l'interdiction des armes à feu réelles
sur les plateaux de cinéma elle a
récolté 25 mille signatures pour en
parler on retrouve thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
soir thomas l'enquète continue donc pour
déterminer les causes du coup de feu
fatal qui a fait beaucoup parler
aujourd'hui les investigations mettre en
évidence le manque de sécurité sur les
plateaux de tournage
oui selon des documents judiciaires qui
ont été dévoilés ce lundi par la presse
c'est au moment où l'acteur alec baldwin
était en train de s'entraîner à dégainer
son arme que le coup de feu mortel a été
tiré on rappelle que pour le moment les
enquêteurs privilégient la thèse
accidentelle ils ont mené un certain
nombre d'auditions dont évidemment celle
de l'acteur alec baldwin c'était
vendredi et puis les inquiète les
enquêteurs s'intéressent
particulièrement aux rôles de deux
personnes d'abord il ya l'armure hier
qu'ils travaillaient sur ce tournage
puisque c'est elle qui a préparé larmes
dont s'est servi alec baldwin et puis il
ya l'assistant réalisateur puisque c'est
lui qui a donné cette arme alec baldwin
et depuis plusieurs jours depuis
plusieurs heures on assiste à des
témoignages de la part d'anciens
collaborateurs de cet assistant
réalisateur et qui explique qu'ils ne
participaient pas à instaurer une
ambiance de sécurité sur les tournages
sur lesquelles il avait travaillé en
laissant notamment libre cours à des
pratiques dangereuses les enquêteurs
devront donc maintenant à en déterminer
quels manquements ont pu conduire à ce
tir qui a donc été fatal et thomas après
ce drame les appels à bagnères les armes
sur les tournages se multiplient
oui cette affaire a pris une tournure
symbolique pour l'opinion américaine
particulièrement pour les personnes qui
travaillent dans le milieu du cinéma il
ya donc cette pétition qui circule en
ligne qui a recueilli à l'heure actuelle
25 mille signatures et qui appellent à
un meilleur encadrement des armes à feu
et plus généralement de meilleures
conditions de sécurité pour les équipes
techniques sur les tournages il ya des
voix qui s'élèvent à hollywood pour
trouver des alternatives à ces armes à
feu c'est le cas par exemple de cet
acteur qui a été interrogée lors d'un
festival de cinéma en californie écouté
et je ne sais pas ce qui va changer mais
il semble que quelque chose doit changer
je ne sais pas si c'est une question de
budget comme j'ai été sur des films à
gros budgets ou cela semble être des
gros navires beaucoup plus organisés ou
les protocoles de sécurité sont très
strictes et puis vous faites des films
indépendants un petit budget et ils
n'ont tout simplement pas le temps où
l'argent donc c'est quelque chose qui
doit être une priorité plus que toute
autre chose c'est comme la sécurité de
l'équipe et des acteurs j'espère que
quelque chose changera tu ne sais pas
vraiment comment parler autrement sauf
que c'est vraiment triste et oui
j'espère qu'ils trouveront vite une
solution car cela doit être plus
important que tout autre chose que
l'argent ou n'importe quoi
beaucoup d'acteurs et de réalisateurs
poussent en ce moment justement pour une
modification drastique des conditions de
tournage avec des armes à feu aux états
unis et puis il ya ce sénateur démocrate
de californie qui souhaite lui instaurer
dans la loi inscrire dans la loi ces
modifications drastiques écoutez un
extrait du communiqué qu'il a publié ce
week end
notre industrie du divertissement doit
faire un meilleur travail pour assurer
des conditions de travail sûres à nos
équipes qui travaillent dur j'ai
l'intention de présenter un projet de
loi qui interdirait les balles réelles
sur les plateaux de tournage en
californie afin d'éviter ce type de
violence insensés et de pertes en vies
humaines
voilà une preuve de l'importance qu'a
pris cette affaire qui pourrait donc
servir d'électrochoc et qui pourrait
conduire à une modification en
profondeur des conditions de tournage
dans les studios américains merci thomas
abonnés en direct de washington est
justement on va poser à la question un
spécialiste laurent cesari professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
d'arras spécialiste des états unis
bonsoir monsieur cesari merci d'être
avec nous thomas bonne et ouvre la
question ça pourrait peut-être faire
changer les réglementations cette sombre
affaire dont évidemment qui a fait
parler puisqu'il s'agit d'un acteur
célèbre qui a qui apportait donc ce coup
de feu ça peut selon vous vraiment
aboutir à quelque chose ces lettres
perdues alors en californie oui
peut-être dans la mesure où que vous
savez la législation varient selon les
états et effectivement là les élus de
californie je pense notamment à la
sénatrice dianne feinstein qui va
bientôt se retirer maintenant ont
toujours été en pointe sur la
réglementation des armes à feu est
effectivement comme la loi concernée
concernerait avant tout les studios
hollywoodiens ça ça relève du droit
local donc ça serait possible en
revanche à un niveau
fédéral c'est plus difficile parce que
on est dans nos frais dans une mesure
qui ne relèverait pas delà de la
conciliation budgétaire donc il faudrait
une majorité de 60 et vous savez qu'elle
est très difficile à obtenir en ce
moment qu'est ce qui coince sur pour
élargir ce débat sur les armes aux états
unis ce sont tout simplement les
mentalités des américains qui veulent
tout simplement continuer à garder la
rame ou c'est ce fameux lobby dont on
parle souvent l'année rires d'ailleurs
un des acteurs hollywoodiens charlton
heston était très en pointe sur sur les
défenses des armes il ya le second
amendement qui de la constitution qui
dit que deux comme une milice était un
droit d' est un droit essentiel une
milice de deux citoyens le le port des
armes ne sera pas ne sera pas interdit
enfin je paraphrase
et avec sa tête alors à partir de ça en
2008 la cour suprême a estimé que le
début de la phrase est relatif à la
milice était une simple clause de style
qui introduisait la proposition est
essentielle à savoir le droit des
citoyens quels qu'ils soient à avoir des
armes mais il ya toute une école qui et
c'est assez logique d'ailleurs qui dit
que non c'est le droit de porter des
armes est relatif à l'existence d'une
milice est effectivement logiquement
s'il n'y avait pas de relation entre les
deux pourquoi avoir mis ce début de
phrase est donc là évidemment comme
commune comme il ya belle lurette cas
par la garde nationale il ya plus de
milices à proprement parler on pourrait
très bien eux légiférer mais là ça
supposait d'aller contre un arrêt de la
cour suprême de 2008 d'avoir une
majorité de 60 c'est lourd à en voir les
américains selon les chiffres en tout
cas nous fournissent la suisse mme aux
larmes sauver 1 il aurait en moyenne
sont marc arme à feu pour 100 habitants
aux états unis en ne comptant que
l'artillerie est détenue par par des
civils c'est pareil c'est énorme
effectivement c'est une proportions
colossales par rapport au reste du monde
cela dit les de la possession d'armes
est en fait
autant content qu'on sache le fait d'une
minorité de la population mais des gens
qui sont véritablement
passionné par sa et qui ont chacun un
véritable petit arsenal est donc
effectivement ce sont des gens
extrêmement comment dire actif au niveau
au niveau au niveau du lobbying est donc
là effectivement il ya une difficulté
je pense je crois que c'est très ça
serait difficile de 2 de venir à bout de
prendre comme on dirait les lillois les
lois locales sont diverses effectivement
vous avez certains états comme la
californie très souple new york très
strict tout comme la caroline du nord où
si j'ose dire on peut se balader dans la
rue sans sans aucune difficulté avec des
armes en revanche ce qui est possible
mais c'est le que dans le plan
d'investissement de byden il ya un volet
ya un volet social comme vous savez
keith richards jour au fur et à mesure
que le vote arrive mais il ya
effectivement tout un volet qui coûte
qu'avec un budget d'environ 6 milliards
de dollars courants sur 8 ans et visant
non pas interdire le port d'armé
introduire des mesures de prévention du
genre l'éducation de la population
justice restaurative et c'est donc et le
thomas ap ce que tu as un procureur de
l'état de new york qui a lancé ce
programme et qui a été repris par by
dane donc dans sa campagne est très
content trouve que c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant cela dit comme
effectivement tout ce programme byden se
réduit de jour en jour nous saurons au
moment du vote si ce volet là et
conserver ou non alors à propos de joe
biden en janvier dernier le washington
post rapporté que certains américains se
ruent vers les magasins d'armement sur
le premier mois de l'année 2021 un pic
de 80% par rapport à janvier de l'année
précédente en cause nous dit au
washington post l'arrivée de de bayda
favorables à une législation plus
stricte sur les sur les armes à feu ça
dit quoi ça
c'est dit que c'est peu de nouveauté
absolue que c'était déjà la même chose
avec obama à l'arrivée d'obama on a eu
en 2008 à new york également d'un seul
coup un pic un pic sur sur les achats
d'armes parce qu'on sait très bien que
en gros les républicains sont comme deux
bannières sont conservateurs dont qui
disent épaules ce n'est pas le droit de
porter des armes qui est en question il
suffit de réprimer fortement ceux qui
ceux qui en font un amant un mauvais
usage et puis on sait bien que les
démocrates sont plus favorables
réglementation donc tout le reste du
lait des comportements
voilà ce qu'on disait au début de cette
interview c'est un problème qui n'en
finira jamais aux états unis et qui
semble
pérenne
aux états unis des limitations au niveau
fédéral sont possibles on peut imaginer
que le droit soit autorisée en principe
et avec de multiples limitation d'euros
sur son exercice un peu comme si on
arrivait pour l'avortement mais ces
limitations elle même supposer une
majorité de 60 et là comme vous savez
avec comment dire tout coince à cause de
la faible majorité de [ __ ] de
certains démocrates
même si des cinémas qui sont les
véritables droits de washington
actuellement et qui bloque absolument
tout en tout cas voilà pour pour finir
un chiffre 1 486 morts par accident en
2019 aux états unis accident par arme à
feu merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec
nous lors ans et harry
et nous avons apporté votre éclairage
voit
dans le reste de l'actualité 1355
nouveaux logements vont sortir de terre
prochainement en cisjordanie occupée une
réunion est prévue cette semaine pour
entériner le projet au total 2000
construction prévue dans les prochains
mois une colonisation par israël de la
cisjordanie et de jérusalem est annexée
pourtant jugées illégales au regard du
droit international elle est également
vivement dénoncée par les palestiniens
cyrielle benavides mille bulles ont
un projet immobilier d'ampleur le
ministère de la construction a annoncé
ce dimanche via un communiqué vouloir
bâtir davantage de logements israéliens
en cisjordanie occupée des appels
d'offres pour 1355 logement dans les
localités de judée samarie ont été
publiés sous la direction du ministre de
la construction
zeev elkin ces nouvelles habitations
viennent s'ajouter à celles annoncées en
août dernier ramenant le total à plus de
2000 logements
israël doit mener ce projet dans cette
colonie juive mais l'emplacement choisi
demeure controversée notamment rentré d
palestine
l'annnonce de 2862 nouvelles unités de
logement et la légalisation de deux
nouvelles colonies et logements au coeur
de la ville d'hébron n'est rien d'autre
qu'une agression flagrante contre notre
terre à la horde bénin il est triste de
voir que quand l'extrême droite se
félicite que l'état d'israël est
quasiment annexée la palestine les
partisans au sein du gouvernement de la
solution à deux états reste mais c'est
une violation du droit international
la politique d'israël en cisjordanie
occupée et qu'il est égal et met en
péril la solution à deux états et la
chance d'arriver à une paix juste
la cisjordanie territoires palestiniens
occupés depuis 1967 par l'armée
israélienne compte 475 mille colons
juifs contre deux millions huit cent
mille palestiniens
si le projet de construction doit encore
être validé par le ministre de la
défense cette semaine il a déjà franchi
beaucoup d'étapes
tous les gouvernements israéliens depuis
honteux vrai en faveur de la
colonisation mais elle s'est accélérée
sous l'impulsion de benyamin nétanyahou
et surtout après l'arrivée de son allié
donald trump à la maison blanche
tous les regards sont tournés ce soir
vers le soudan situation confuse suite à
un coup d'état après l'arrestation du
premier ministre d'état d'urgence est
décrété dans le pays le réseau internet
est coupé lui aussi dans les rues de
nombreuses manifestations protestent
contre les militaires à khartoum l'armée
a tiré faisant d'ailleurs trois morts et
80 blessés on fait le point avec nicolas
petit
des rues barrées par des pneus enflammés
le réveil a été pour le moins mouvementé
ce lundi matin à khartoum
la raison de ce mouvement de révolte le
coup d'état mené par le général fatah
albou roanne qui dirigeait le conseil de
souveraineté qu'il a lui-même dissous ce
lundi midi
[Musique]
premièrement l'état d'urgence est
déclaré dans tout le pays
deuxièmement le pays reste attaché au
contenu de la déclaration
constitutionnelle de la période
intérimaire en 2019 et à l'accord au
soudan du sud qui a été signé à jouba en
octobre 2020
troisièmement certains articles de la
constitution sont suspendus les 11 12 15
16 24 tiers 71 et 72 et nous restons
engagés envers les accords
internationaux signés pendant le règne
du gouvernement intérimaire
alors que la plupart des ministres et
des civils du conseil de transition ont
été arrêtés l'armée a également tiré à
balles réelles sur les très nombreux
protestataires des opposants au putsch
qui appelle la population à se révolter
en réalité ce que l'armée est en train
de faire maintenant est une grande
trahison envers les citoyens à tous les
niveaux il est maintenant important que
chaque citoyen sudan et agissent et
descendre dans la rue pour empêcher tout
véhicule armé de chacune
entièrement la déclaration du général al
bourhane nous revendiquons un
gouvernement civil et demandons la
dissolution du conseil militaire nous ne
négocierons plus avec l'armée notre
peuple est persévérant et patient il
continuera à exiger un gouvernement
civil le peuple soudanais déjà mobilisés
la semaine dernière des dizaines de
milliers de personnes avaient manifesté
pour soutenir le transfert complet du
pouvoir aux civils un peu plus de deux
ans après l'éviction d'omar el-béchir le
soudan s'apprête à vivre des moments
très tendue et reste loin de la
stabilité à laquelle il aspire
crise soudanaise qui inquiète la
communauté internationale le secrétaire
général de l'onu condamne un coup d'état
militaire et appelle à la libération du
chef du gouvernement et ses ministres
une sortie similaire aux nombreuses
réactions internationales de paris à
washington en passant par l'union
africaine ou bruxelles
la france condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté la tentative de coup d'état au
soudan j'exprime notre soutien au
gouvernement de transition sous d'année
et appelle à la libération immédiate et
au respect de l'intégrité
premiers ministres et des dirigeants
civils
préoccupé par le fait que les forces
militaires soudanaises pourrait placer
le premier ministre abdellah mbock en
résidence surveillée ainsi que d'autres
membres de la direction civile allaient
nous demandons leur libération rapide ch
10 les etats unis sont profondément
alarmé par les informations faisant état
d'une prise de contrôle militaire du
gouvernement de transition cela serait
contraire à la déclaration
constitutionnelle et aux aspirations
démocratiques du peuple soudanais est
tout à fait inacceptable
comme nous l'avons dit à plusieurs
reprises tout changement de gouvernement
de transition par la force mais tu en
danger l'aide américaine points depuis
la destitution d'omar el béchir en 2019
le soudan est plongé dans sa
reconstruction politique retour sur ces
derniers mois d'instabilité chronique
avec adrien fonteneau
c'était il ya plus de deux ans le 11
avril 2019 après six jours de
manifestations devant le quartier
général de l'armée à khartoum la
capitale omar el béchir est destitué
arrivé au pouvoir en 1989 par un coup
d'état le président soudanais est alors
remplacé par un conseil militaire de
transition la population dénonce un
nouveau coup d'état et la répression est
sanglante à l'été 2010 9 les
interventions militaires font plus de
250 morts parmi les manifestants mais
dans le même temps un accord de
transition et trouver les militaires
partageront le pouvoir avec les civils
le tout arbitré par un conseil de
souveraineté à sa tête le général abdel
fattah al burhan au poste de premier
ministre c'est abdallah amdocs ancien
économiste de l'onu qui est nommé
forceps pendant trente ans nous étions
isolés du reste du monde traités comme
des parias mais maintenant nous sommes
de retour parmi les belles nation of
good news
omar el béchir destitué et huit mois
plus tard jugé le 14 décembre 2019 l'ex
président soudanais est condamné à deux
ans de prison pour corruption et le 22
une autre enquête démarre le dirigeant
africain est visé par la cour pénale
internationale pour génocide crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité dans
son pays après l'accord de transition
c'est seulement le 3 octobre 2020 qu'un
accord de paix est enfin trouvée signé
par le gouvernement et les forces
rebelles celui ci doit mettre fin à dix
sept ans d'une guerre meurtrière sur la
bonne voie le soudan est également
retiré de la liste américaine des pays
soutenant le terrorisme
mais le pays reste fragile en février
dernier abdallah amdocs dévoile un
nouveau gouvernement avec sept ministres
issus de groupes rebelles à l'époque
d'omar el béchir un gouvernement en
difficulté huit mois plus tard à la
normale que je n'exagère pas si je dit
il s'agit de la fia crise et la crise
plus dangereuse qui menace la transition
et même notre pays tout entier et qui
annonce un mal terrible sorti depuis dix
jours pro armée et civile en faveur de
la démocratie manifeste en permanence
jusqu'au coup de force ce lundi et
l'arrestation des dirigeants soudanais
par les militaires
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison à le soudan le dire qui
connaît une transition précaires ont
tâché de divisions politiques et de
luttes de pouvoir pourquoi une telle
crise et pourquoi maintenant le soudan a
vécu pendant trente ans sous la férule
de el béchir est effacée mal terminée
puisque naturellement la population
manifestait et finalement ça s'est mal
terminée il ya deux ans seulement
lorsque une partie de l'armée et
l'essentiel de l'armée a soutenu la
population pour faire partir ou el
béchir qui avait qui étaient totalement
usées après 30 ans de pouvoir et l'armée
a préféré en effet
organiser son départ mais évidemment
depuis cette période il ya un
gouvernement de transition qui est
composé de moitié de militaires et de
moitié de civils et on est aujourd'hui à
peu près à la mi temps cette transition
puisqu'il va y avoir des élections en
principe en 2023 donc évidemment c'est
le moment où les frictions apparaissent
parce que il ya peut-être des
divergences de vue entre les militaires
et les civils qui étaient au
gouvernement de transition puis à
l'intérieur du groupe civile il ya
divers partis politiques par conséquent
il ya aussi des frictions pour
l'organisation des élections en 2023 et
finalement et bien depuis plusieurs
semaines courait la rumeur d'un coup
d'état à carte où d'ailleurs il y avait
eu des manifestations qui disait ça
suffit ce gouvernement est incapable il
faut que les militaires le pouvoir et
mettre un peu d'ordre il y avait des
manifestations contre la prise du
pouvoir par les militaires et finalement
ce matin les militaires ont pris le
pouvoir
ça n'est pas une véritable surprise
c'est triste parce que ce pays
évidemment est un peu martyrisé il a
connu une guerre civile très longue il
est amputé de la partie sud il ya dix
ans puisque le soudan du sud est devenu
indépendant qu'il a dû accepter son
adhérence et c'est là que se trouvent
les puits de pétrole est ce que ça veut
dire vous dites voilà ça fait un petit
moment que ça couvait est ce que ça
aurait pu être évité
je n'en suis pas sûr parce que les
militaires n'ont jamais lâché la main
ils ont toujours gardé le contrôle des
opérations depuis la chute d'el béchir
en réalité et même s'ils ont laissé les
civils prendre un certain nombre de
positions de ministère et de ses les
autres leur ont permis naturellement de
s'exprimer dans leur compte dans le
champ de leurs compétences mais les
militaires étaient toujours là et
probablement que ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'ils ont eu peur que la chose de
réchappe parce que les civils prenait de
plus en plus d'initiatives à l'intérêt
de ce gouvernement et que les militaires
entendent bien que ce soit eux qui
régule cette transition et la population
dans tout ça certains se damner sont
dans la rue disent refuser ce régime
militaire et deux se disent même prêts à
sacrifier leur vie pour la transition
démocratique
ça va s'aggraver pour eux je crois qu'il
faut l'avoir dire que c'est l'un des
pays les plus pauvres de la planète
je crois qu'il a le rang 170 sur 197
quelque chose comme ça c'est un pays
d'une extrême pauvreté par conséquent
bien sûr les gens descendent dans la rue
parce qu'ils sont mécontents
certains ont pu être mobilisés par les
militaires la semaine dernière pour
demander la prise du pouvoir par les
militaires mais ils ont été
instrumentalisés aujourd'hui
effectivement les manifestations sont
contre la prise du pouvoir par les
militaires parce qu'une majorité de la
population se rend compte que ça n'est
certainement pas la bonne solution pour
aller vers un régime démocratique vers
des élections régime démocratique que ce
pays n'a pratiquement jamais connu
depuis son indépendance alors le général
de radin qui a dissout donc aujourd'hui
ces autorités de transition dit qu'il
respectera les accords internationaux
signés par le soudan que prévoient les
accords alors il ya plusieurs accords
internationaux il ya d'abord l'accord
comme je le disais tout à l'heure de
2011 qui prévoit l'indépendance du
soudan du sud et bien entendu il n'est
pas question de remettre en cause cet
accord sanctionné par les nations unies
il ya d'autre part
un accord dont on ne parle pas beaucoup
c'est que ce gouvernement de transition
est l un des pays et l'inde et les
gouvernements de pays arabes qui a
normalisé ses relations avec israël sous
la pression américaine sous la pression
de l'administration et par conséquent ça
veut dire que probablement il ne
remettra pas en cause cette cette
évolution considérable pour un régime
islamiste et puis il ya effectivement
aussi toutes les règles de la transition
qui sont sanctionnés par la communauté
internationale d'ailleurs on a vu que
l'union africaine aujourd'hui s'est
montrée très inquiète de cette prise de
pouvoir par les militaires qui constitue
naturellement on peut faire la
communauté internationale eh bien elle
peut faire un certain nombre de choses
parce qu'elle a quand même la main sur
l'aide l'aide humanitaire l'aide
économique l'aide financière ce pays est
pratiquement sous perfusion j'ai dit
qu'il était l'un des plus pauvres du
monde et le général qui a pris le
pouvoir et la junte militaire vont être
obligés de composer avec la communauté
internationale pour obtenir le maintien
de cette aide humanitaire pour obtenir
le maintien de l'aide américaine et pour
obtenir le maintien de l'aide de du fmi
et de la banque mondiale et des autres
bailleurs de fonds y compris l'union
européenne merci beaucoup claudin
blanche saison merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
et la politique africaine toujours avec
un test grandeur nature à
l'international pour la nouvelle
première ministre tunisienne la boue des
nets en arabie saudite pour un sommet
consacré à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
l'occasion pour elle à d'affiner les
pourparlers avec les saoudiens qui ont
promis un soutien financier à tunis en
pleine crise sanitaire plus de précision
avec notre correspondant en tunisie
bassem chez lui
une première visite officielle sous le
signe de l'écologie et des négociations
l'aja bouden est arrivé hier soir sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport de ryad pour sa
première visite dans le royaume saoudien
en tant que nouvelle chef du
gouvernement tunisien accompagné du
ministre des affaires étrangères othman
jerandi et de la ministre de
l'environnement les lâches hirawi neige
la bouteille doit participer pendant
deux jours au sommet de l'initiative
verte du moyen orient une initiative
lancée par le prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite mohamed ben salman pour définir
une feuille de route commune au monde
arabe dans la protection de la place
aides et de la nature en mars dernier la
tunisie avait adhéré à cette initiative
écologique dont l'un des objectifs est
la plantation de 50 milliards d'arbres
dans tout le moyen-orient pour réduire
les émissions carbone de 2 5% ryad
entend ancrer la première alliance de
lutte contre le changement climatique au
moyen-orient par le biais d'une
plate-forme d'experts et de capital
financier pour tunis ce sommet est
l'occasion de participer à une
initiative internationale dans la
promotion de l'écologie n'est pas
seulement le choix de l'arabie saoudite
pour la première visite officielle de
najlae bouden est principalement due à
la crise financière que traverse son
pays un déplacement qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre des négociations relatives au
soutien financier vital promis par iad à
tunis au bord de la faillite la tunisie
s'est récemment tourné vers l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats arabes unis deux
pays frères qui pourrait débloquer 3 à 5
milliards de dollars pour éviter la
jeune démocratie de connaître un
scénario à la grecque ou à la libanaise
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de chahine à la jeune
victime d'un viol collectif poignardé et
brûlé vive il ya deux genres jours qu'on
jouera creil et en région parisienne
dont quelques minutes place à notre
regret qu'on pense les français nous
irons à la rencontre des proches de
l'adolescente de 15 ans un entourage qui
demande que justice soit faite
vous venez
[Musique]
on
s'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai car fois un
vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc il ya une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière
a ajouté à la scène gastronomique
mondiale
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
tout son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention on est dans un
système très curatif 1 c'est essentiel
d'avoir l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon le
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul vers moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays redevient sur partout partout
vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés vos des usines roues on
n'aimait rien du tout comme carbone dans
l' usine que ce soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde donc là
la conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai car froid
un vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc il ya une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière a ajouté à la scène
gastronomique mondiale
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire cet assassinat qu'il y beaucoup
plus haut sur la place des femmes et de
la sexualité dans les citer cette phrase
signée de l'avocate de la famille de
shana cette jeune fille victime d'un
viol collectif poignardée puis brûlée
vive il y a deux ans jour pour jour à
creil l'entourage de l'adolescente de 15
ans demande la vérité sur cette affaire
et surtout que justice soit faite
[Musique]
marche blanche donc en hommage à shane a
aujourd'hui à creil dans l'oise en 2019
cette jeune fille de 15 ans avaient été
assassinés puis brûlé dans un cabanon un
rassemblement l'initiative de
l'association justice pour shane naples
jamais sa montée par ses proches le lieu
du drame devait accueillir un mémorial
prochainement aujourd'hui ses bras
proches se bat toujours pour que justice
soit faite fmi à la recherche de la
vérité une situation qui rend le deuil
difficile à faire on retrouve en direct
de créer notre reporter nadège
abderrazak bonsoir à nadège l'émotion et
le désir de justice évidemment été les
maîtres mots de cette marche blanche
absolument stéphanie vive émotion ce
matin a créé lors de cette marche
blanche en hommage à shine adolescente
de 15 ans vous l'avez dire
poignardé et brûlé vive est retrouvée
morte il y a deux ans jours pour jours
dans un cabanon à des jardins familiaux
ici dans cette cité à creil alors sa
famille ses proches ses amis se sont
réunis aujourd'hui des élus locaux est
également le maire de la ville de creil
a participé à cette marche blanche
aujourd'hui pour rendre hommage à la
mémoire de cette adolescente qui a vécu
un véritable calvaire et puis son
calvaire il a commencé deux ans à part à
deux ans auparavant puisqu'elle a été
victime d'un viol collectif en 2017 les
images de ce viol collectif ont été tout
de suite partager sur les réseaux
sociaux alors les participants à cette
marche blanche ont défilé dans les rues
pour et bien se rapprocher sur les lieux
de découverte du corps de la petite
shayna où ils ont profité 1 pourrait
bien déposer des fleurs donc je vous
propose d'écouter son père et le frère
de cette jeune fille m'a fait en 2002 va
pas tenter sa fille des portes ça va
finir tout le temps j'ai ma fille
bientôt ça va finir les enquêteurs le
tribunal ils ont tout ça bientôt ça va
finir 1 ma fille allait les plus
d'arbres à 2017 2019 j'ai même pas été
jugé encore les suppôts 7 2 6
1 aujourd'hui c'est vrai bond toutefois
du mal tout temps je dois de me coller
un temps je fais que j'ai confiée à la
justice je vous remercie aussi tout le
monde qui présents aujourd'hui qui nous
soutient aussi dans certaine façon c'est
vrai que au début on est restés
silencieux c'est cette affaire parce que
c'était déjà pas facile pour nous d'y
croire même c'était très très très très
difficile après les choses se sont
enchaînées on a pu trouver
quelqu'un au jour d'aujourd'hui il je
sais que lui dans le droit ou voilà on
se dit innocent mais pour nous pour moi
ma famille nous on sait très bien que
c'est lui parce que il ya des preuves
avant de pouvoir faire son deuil cette
famille attend justice attend que
justice soit faite pour les deux
affaires pour les viols de 2010 était
pour le meurtre de la petite china en
j'espère pouvoir alerter dans mon
discours que sahin a pas qu'à nous
reposons tout notre espoir sur la
justice aujourd'hui on n'a que ça on
attend seulement que la justice façon
son travail deux ans après au quotidien
d'une famille détruite
c'est vraiment difficile pour nous
j'avais bien que la justice française
sera bon bon nous ont fait confiance à
la justice les enquêtés ont fait
confiance nous aurons fait contre 1,15
justice mais j'aimerais bien qu'il ait
une peine exemplaire
l avocat temps de la famille m haéri est
optimiste quant aux chances d'obtenir
justice dans cette affaire je vous
propose de l'écouter
les faits sont contestés en face nous de
notre côté on est assez serein et on
pense que les charges qui pèsent contre
le mis en cause sont suffisantes le
renvoyer aux assises et puis ensuite il
y aura une audience aux assises à
l'issue de laquelle on aura un délibéré
concernant donc les heures précédentes
donc les deux affaires avait été ouverte
à l'instruction la première celle de
2017 qui avait été ouverte pour viols en
réunion a été correctionnalisé et
l'audience devrait avoir lieu d'ici
quelques semaines quelques mois on n'a
pas encore la date précise mais ça
devrait être assez rapide probablement
avant l'audience aux assises si jamais
la chambre d'instruction confirmé
l'ordonnancé de renvoi devant la cour
d'assises info la troisième affaire est
la deuxième affaire est toujours à
l'instruction parce que china avait
porté plainte en fait pour les deux
premières affaires et les deux hommes
d'affaires avaient été portés devant le
juge d'instruction à l'instruction puis
la troisième affaire a été évidemment
ouverte à l'instruction puisqu'il
s'agissait d'un crime un assassinat
deux affaires qui elle devrait donc bien
trop être jugés devant les tribunaux le
principal suspect de la mort de chanas
et bien devrait être jugé début 2000 22
devant la cour d'assises dès mineurs de
l'oise
mercinat déjà des razak en direct de
creil alors quand on vit dans les
banlieues et qu'on est une femme la vie
est elle plus difficile l'assassinât de
shana relève t-il un véritable problème
révèle-t-il est un problème de société
les femmes sont elles libres dans les
quartiers on attend vos réactions ce
soir sur le conte télégramme d'ayrté
france place au face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct avec nous à lima items
infirmières ex candidate de l'union des
démocrates musulmans français à la
mairie de paris bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau julien
oudoul porte parole du rassemblement
national merci d'être avec nous
également chahine à 15 ans poignardé
brûlée vive à creil c'est bien plus
qu'un fait divers julien odoul c'est un
fait de société dont on parle ce soir
oui malheureusement c'est devenu un fait
de société les femmes de notre pays et
plus spécifiquement plus
particulièrement dans les quartiers sont
aujourd'hui menacés un grand nombre de
femmes sont menacées elles ne peuvent
plus s'habiller comme elles le
souhaitent ne peuvent plus déplacés se
dépasser comme elle le souhaite elles ne
peuvent plus être libre dans l'espace
public nous le constatons de plus en
plus c'est d'ailleurs les épisodes
dramatiques se multiplient
quelquefois qui vont jusqu'au jusqu'au
meurtre malheureusement beaucoup de
femmes essaient de s'extirper de ses
quartiers de leur famille de leur
environnement communautaire avec
difficulté avec courage et il faut les
saluer il faut les accompagner il faut
que l'état soit à leurs côtés évidemment
pour lesquels puce s'émanciper tout
simplement et puis il faut s'attaquer
évidemment aux causes de l'enfermement
des femmes et aux causes de leur mise en
danger c'est principalement le fait
d'une idéologie religieuse qui est
d'islamisme et quand l'islamisme devient
la norme sociale majoritaire dans
certains quartiers malheureusement
malheureusement c'est des droits et
libertés des femmes qui régresse qui
recule et qui sont menacés donc c'est
contre cette idéologie qu'il faut
évidemment se battre avec tous les mois
des moyens de l'état avec du courage
politique pour faire en sorte que les
françaises partout sur le territoire
national et les mêmes droits et des
mêmes chances à ymare high-tech pour
l'avocate de la famille je vous laisse
évidemment rebondir sur les propos de
julien houle mais dans la continuité un
l'avocat de la famille qui dit cet
assassinat dit beaucoup de choses sur
eux
la place des femmes et de la sexualité
dans les cités votre réponse vous
adhérez justement ce constat de
l'avocate et julien en double qui
rajoute effectivement
certains éléments sur ce qu'ils pensent
être la cause
je vais pas en remettre en question qui
est des agressions et malheureusement
des viols et jusqu'au meurtre assassinat
ça je vais pas le remettre en question
que ce soit dans les banlieues ou
ailleurs c'est un fait ça
c'est un fait qui est vrai mais diable
et est incontestable mais ce que je
remets en question c'est encore une fois
cette stigmatisation et est le cheval de
bataille de monsieur
qui est la même et de kits qui dans
borie tambourine toujours la même chose
le même son kinani harmonie ni sens
c'est à dire toujours les banlieues
toujours les
l'islamisme les musulmans etc donc on en
a un petit peu assez ce n'est pas le
stigmatiser pas les islamistes
vous ne stigmatisez pas les ennemis de
la république que sont les islamistes
sont les noms ou sans les islamistes
vous parlez de 10 mai de d'immigration
de masse et pas simplement d'islamistes
les islamistes où vous vous montrez les
mois montrer les mois et je vous dirai
oui y'a pas de soucis il n'y a pas de
problème mais vous vous stigmatisez les
banlieues en général à quel moment vous
avez dit simplement les islamistes et
stop vous dites les musulmans vient de
le défendre les banlieues
que vous stigmatisez de racailles sans
arrêt sans arrêt et c'est pénible parce
que ce vous n'arrêtez pas de tambouriner
toujours la même chose encore une fois
par des sons qui n'ont ni harmonie nonis
ans contre concentrez vous s'il vous
plaît et là je le dis avec avec en toute
humilité
concentrez vous s'il vous plaît sur des
choses très concrètes et réelles qui
impacte qui impacte
le quotidien des français notamment des
françaises
sur sûr bien sûr sur des violences mais
c'est pas simplement dans les banlieues
mamma mia je me permets d'intervenir
effectivement julien oduya a rajouté
cette question je cite deux l'islamisme
pour lui mais là c'est l'avant cadre de
la famille qui dit cet assassinat nie
beaucoup de choses sur la place des
femmes et de la sexualité dans les cités
c'est une idée vous que vous rejetez
l'idée de la place des femmes et de la
sexualité dans les cités s'il ya deux
idées différentes effectivement je ne
rejette pas
la stigmatisation la sexualité les
violences qui sont qui sont faites en
banlieue qui ont lieu en banlieue dans
les banlieues et dans certains quartiers
je ne leur jette pas encore une fois ce
que je rejette c'est cette
stigmatisation sur les banlieues où à
chaque fois on nous parle de banlieue on
parle de violence on parle pas des
belles choses qui sont faites on parle
pas des habitants des milliers
d'habitants qui sont la paix et qui sont
qui vivent en harmonie ça monsieur doux
l'oublier
donc dans ce cas là l'avocate a tout à
fait raison que je ne peux pas le jeu ne
peut pas le remettre en question mais
pareil et comment s'est
il ya une montée de violence de toute
façon que ce soit dans les banlieues ou
ailleurs et ça s'explique
ça ne s'explique pas seulement par ça ne
s'explique pas seulement par par le fait
que ce soit des musulmans ou
des personnes qui me issus de
l'immigration mais ils sont dans il vit
dans une sauce dans une sectorisation
dans une politique d'urbanisation qui a
des décennies on a marqué des gens
depuis des années des amis on les a
oubliés oui monsieur odoul je sais que
vous n'aimez pas qu'on se plaint mais
malheureusement les fêtes les faits sont
là ça n'excuse en rien les violences
encore une fois ne faites pas dire ce
que j'ai je n'ai pas dit gêné en double
sur le fait qu'on parque effectivement
les gens et qui est une forme de
responsabilité aussi de la part de
l'état votre réponse c'est le discours
qu'on entend depuis 30 ans c'est à dire
c'est de la faute de l'urbanisme c'est
de la faute de la ghettoïsation je tiens
à dire qu'aucune banlieues en france n'a
de baronnie de frontières il n'y a pas
de ghetto en france alors oui à une
politique d'immigration certes qui a été
anarchique qui a été massive qui a
constitué le terreau du communautarisme
et ce même communaux harris mme a
engendré la propagation d'une idéologie
que peut-être que vous ne voulez pas
voir qui est celle de l'islam politique
qui se propage dans bon nombre de
quartiers et qui aujourd'hui supplantent
les lois de la république c'est ça le
véritable problème c'est que quand les
lois de la république que sont
minoritaires quand elles reculent du
fait de l'islamisme ce sont les droits
des femmes qui recule et je tiens à dire
que vous parlez d'harmonie dans les
banlieues nous on stigmatise pas les
habitants des banlieues vous savez les
habitants des banlieues ce sont déjà des
victimes des victimes de l'insécurité la
majorité l'immense majorité des
françaises et des français qui habitent
les banlieues qui sont d'origine
immigrée ou qui ne le sont pas souffrent
de l'insécurité de la violence et les
premières victimes sont les femmes les
premières victimes sont les femmes ça a
toujours été le cas dans l'histoire
elles sont harcelés au quotidien il ya
un climat de violence qui est
insoutenable insoutenable et s'ajoutent
à cela des normes religieuses qui font
que qui impose une inégalité entre les
hommes et les femmes ce qui est
totalement un conte incompatible avec
nos valeurs avec nos principes
républicains tant qu'on n'arrêtera pas
cette immigration de masse c'est-à-dire
faire venir des personnes qui ne
partagent rien de notre culture qui
préfèrent la charia à l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes dans la
confiance revenir tant qu'on fera venir
ces personnes là les droits des femmes
en france seront menacés tout simplement
donc il faut une reconquête nationale et
républicaine dans ces quartiers il faut
de l'ordre républicain il faut de la
force républicaine il faut réprimer les
islamistes oui parce qu'il y en a de
plus en plus et je peut vous emmener
dans certains quartiers de ma région aux
grésillés à dijon à planoise à besançon
aux champs-plaisants à sens à la petite
hollande à montbéliard ne suffit pas
d'aller en seine-saint-denis pour voir
les islamistes malheureusement il faut
les combattre pied à pied et surtout il
faut arrêter cet aveuglement qui est
insupportable
je veux dire on peut combattre ce mal
ensemble ont peut-être qu'on peut avoir
des différences évidemment et j'entends
ce que vous dites mais clairement nous
avons un ennemi qu'est l'islamisme qui
est le principal ennemi des françaises
aujourd'hui dans notre pays je vous
renvoie
justement le fait de vous venez de dire
arrêter cet aveuglement arrêté aussi cet
aveuglement et 7 ce martèlement contre
les banlieues et les musulmans c'est
c'est à ce moment où vous vous entendez
un martèlement contre les musulmans et
les banlieues mais parce que c'est votre
cheval de bataille que ce soit que ce
soit à quel moment madame j'ai parlé de
musulmans je parle d'islamistes madame
alima et l on va lire ce message
télégramme envoyé par une
téléspectatrice salima les femmes ne
peuvent que très difficilement circuler
un risque en le harcèlement et les
remarques désobligeantes constamment
aujourd'hui il faut s'attaquer à cette
inégalité entre femmes et hommes dans
les quartiers sensibles véritable
problème dit elle qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez à cette femme est manifestement
habite justement dans l'un de ces
quartiers est ce que vous la soutenez
vous vous y répondez quoi comment voulez
vous une fois je ne je ne remets pas en
question qui est des violences dans les
quartiers du quartier dans les banlieues
dans les quatre ans si sur ce qu'elle
n'a dit aujourd'hui le fossat tk7
inégalités entre femmes et hommes dans
les quartiers sensibles est ce que oui
ou et non dans ces quartiers les femmes
faisait les hommes sont inégaux pour
vous
non papa papa pour ma part ils ne sont
pas illégaux moi j'ai vécu dans un
quartier j'ai vécu dans une cité
et jusqu'à présent je n'ai jamais subi
de violence ou quoi que ce soit je ne
dis pas qu'elles n'existent pas il ya
une recrudescence de violence partout
dans le territoire français que ce soit
à paris 58% des femmes se plaignent
d'une violence une recrudescence de
violence à paris dans les transports à
côté de leur domicile sur le sur le
chemin de l'ordre de 2 de leurs du lieu
de leur travail moi je suis infirmière
et gd j'ai des collègues qui ont été
agressés sur le lieu de travail quand
elle travaille de nuit quand elle rentre
très tôt le matin il fait toujours nuit
parce que parfois on rentre à 7h et et
comme comme dirait la chanson paris
s'éveille
je ne remets pas en question qui est des
violences ce que je remets encore encore
une fois en question c'est qu'on
stigmatise certaine ça on prie pardonnez
moi le message de paix on l'a répété
mais ces vaccins voilà voulu répondre
justement sur cette inégalité c'est ce
que dit salima dans son message julien
odoul un seul exemple qui est
d'actualité pour illustrer cette
inégalité aujourd'hui on a une dame qui
sur une autre chaîne à enlever son voile
pendant 20 secondes pendant 20 secondes
où on a une dame qui a enlevé son voile
elle a reçu sur les réseaux sociaux des
centaines de menaces de morts des
centaines de menaces de mort alors qu'on
nous dit par ailleurs qu' elle est libre
de le porter visiblement elles et elles
ne sont pas libres de l'enlever donc
cesser cette situation là qui est
inacceptable et qu'on voit qu'il ya une
pression communautaire une pression
religieuse sur les femmes dans bon
nombre de quartiers qui leur impose une
façon de se vêtir une façon de se
comporter une façon de se marier et
cetera qui évidemment ne sont pas
imposées aux hommes donc l'inégalité
elle est présente elle est bien présente
dans ces quartiers du fait de
l'islamisme qui impose des règles et qui
la norme sociale majoritaire donc si
vous ne vous attaquez pas aux problèmes
de fond l'islamisme qui est alimenté par
les vagues d'immigration il faut bien le
rappeler vous ne résoudrait pas le
problème d'insécurité qui pèsent sur les
femmes on peut évidemment constaté on
peut dénoncer on peut déplorer mais si
vous vous attaquez pas aux véritables
problèmes qui est le développement de
cette idéologie vous n'apporterait pas
de réponse aux femmes qui souffrent au
quotidien et qui sont obligés dans leur
quotidien vous parliez de trajet pour
aller travailler dans les transports qui
sont obligés tous les jours et moi j'ai
des témoignages de que ce soit dans ma
famille de mes amis ou de collègues qui
sont obligés d'opérer des stratégies
d'évitement comment se vêtir pour ne pas
attirer le regard comment ne pas croiser
tel ou tel comme on dirait tels ou tels
hall d'immeuble comment faire quand on
est sifflé quand on est alpagué par
telle ou telle personne enfin je veux
dire c'est un cauchemar pour bon nombre
de femmes que d'aller dans les
transports pour aller travailler et pour
se déplacer dans l'espace public il faut
bien prendre conscience de ça et il
m'arrive thème là la réponse
encore une fois je ne remets pas en
question certaines violences certaines
différences tout simplement femmes
certaines femmes ne se sentent pas libre
j'ai mis en doute par des cette femme
qui était insulté c'est d'être sur les
réseaux sociaux lorsqu'elle avait enlevé
son voile est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui me guette est ce que vous condamnez
que vous expliquez coalition je ne
cautionne absolument pas ni les insultes
ni les violences quelles qu'elles soient
qu'elle soit verbale ou autre ça ne me
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
je ne cautionne en aucun cas aucune
violence quelle qu'elle soit la liberté
de porter ou non le voile et est
effectif il n'y a pas de sas et c'est
complètement c'est condamnable toutes
ces insultes et ces violences sont
condamnables je les remets pas en
question je pense que le fait de l'avoir
ce qui a sur alimenter et un peu sur
enrichi en enrichit un petit peu le
débat je pense je pense que c'est le
fait qu'elle ait enlevé avec monsieur
zemmour et on s'arrêtera là voilà qui
incarne est qui qui fait son excusez-moi
de 2,2 cette expression mais qui fait
son beurre sur le dos des beurs depuis
plus de 15 ans et donc je pense qu'il ya
un ras-le-bol aussi de la part des
musulmans qui ne sont pas violents ils
ne sont pas tous violents qui ne sont
pas tous extrémistes encore une fois moi
j'ai des frères j'ai un père j'ai des
cousines des cousins etc on n'a jamais
eu je n'ai jamais eu de problèmes avec
mes frères je m'habille comme je veux
j'ai des soeurs qui portent le voile
c'est leur choix personne n'aura à poser
est-ce que vous est-ce qu'un jour
monsieur odoul où vous avez été plus
loin que vous avez été chercher là
la signification du voile est ce que
vous avez une culture qui va au delà de
la culture bfm tv
justement erté peut-être un petit à
niveau un petit peu plus plus plus élevé
je vous entends je vous entends par
exemple
je vous entends parler des banlieues et
c'est de défendre les femmes c'est tout
à votre honneur mais n'en faites pas une
bataille
pour avoir des voix parce que c'est ce
serait se serait
ce serait insulter les femmes
vous en faites votre bataille depuis
quand depuis combien de temps messieurs
mais depuis que je suis engagé en
politique au rassemblement national et
vous savez ce n'est pas une bataille
pour aller chercher des voix c'est une
bataille pour apporter des solutions
face à un défi pour notre civilisation
parce que vous savez quand on a des
droits des femmes des libertés des
femmes qui recule c'est notre
civilisation qui s'effondre et vous
parliez de d'eric zemmour vous savez il
ya quantité de femmes qui veulent vivre
comme des françaises et qu'ils ont payé
quelques fois de leur vie si vous prenez
l'exemple de cette pauvre chahinez qui a
été brûlée vive tout simplement parce
qu'elle voulait s'habiller comme une
française qu'elle vienne
pour en déduire quoi que ce soit c'est
c'est tout à fait condamnable moi je
n'avais pas de dix mois 12pour pour
répondre à l humanité parce qu'elle met
le doigt sur quelque chose comme
d'importance et c'est aussi la
sensibilité de la voilà de beaucoup de
musulmans qui se sentent en ce moment
constamment montré du doigt il faut bien
le dire dans le dans le débat public où
nous trouver cette ligne juste
aujourd'hui dans ce type de débat la
ligne il est clair c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes française
ou français à partir du moment où vous
respectez les lois de la république que
vous respectez la culture que vous
respectez le mode de vie de notre pays
son histoire ses moeurs mais vous n'avez
pas de problème serre que vous êtes
intégré dans la communauté nationale à
partir du moment où vous êtes et par
atistes vous considérez que les lois de
de dieu sont supérieures aux lois des
hommes que finalement vous préféré vivre
comme là bas plutôt que vivre comme chez
nous et donc imposées dans votre
quotidien à aux femmes de votre
environnement des règles qui ne sont pas
les nôtres dans ce cas oui vous n'êtes
pas dans la communauté nationale c'est
tout et tout c'est toute la distinction
nous nous faisons la distinction
juste terminée nous faisons la
distinction et nous considérons n'ya pas
de musulmans en france il ya des
français qui sont de confession
musulmane comme des français de
confession catholique ou juives nous
nous faisons la guerre aux islamistes
c'est à dire ceux qui considèrent que la
loi religieuse est supérieure de la
république et veulent imposer la charia
dans notre pays contre cela évidemment
nous serons intransigeants contre les
français de confession musulmane qui
veulent vivre dans notre pays en paix
respecter nos lois notre culture il ya
évidemment aucun problème et nous serons
de tout coeur avec eux pour faire en
sorte qu'il soit pleinement intégrée qui
se puissent vivre comme des français
simplement elle imara et m je suis votre
raisonnement
vous considérez comme islamistes la
femme que vous avez repris en 2019 qui
portait le voile devant son fils s'est
avéré madame c c'est prouvé c'est une
militante islamiste est éprouvée j'ai lu
d'autres choses qui sont complètement et
madame
excusez moi de vous dire cela mais elle
a été soutenue par le ccf et la critique
sont aujourd'hui dissoute comme d un
fils in neuf rencontres la république
donc c'était une militante de l'islam
politique désolé de vous le dire madame
ça c'est une rumeur que vous appelez ça
une rumeur ce sont les faits sont les
faits non pour pour appuyer votre votre
immonde geste surtout le fait de deux
ans de reprendre d'une vous avez vous
avez témoigné d'une insensibilité
incroyable pendant que son enfant était
en train de pleurer vous avez dit
wippler j'en pleure pleure moi je pleure
pour les orphelins des 263 victimes des
attentats je vais vous vous posez une
question monsieur haut doubs où étiez
vous lors de juste un exemple lors des
attentats du ducasse du 15 novembre 2000
cas de
cass où étiez-vous
pardon ou où j'étais oui j'ai constaté
ça chez moi comme des millions de
français et ben moi en tant que
musulmane et j'étais cadre aux urgences
de saint-antoine l'hôpital saint-antoine
qui a quelques quelques mètres des
premiers des premiers des premiers sites
et à quelques kilomètres du bataclan et
l'allemagne plus quoi vous dites
musulmanes dans ce cadre là laissez-moi
aller au delà de jusqu'au bout de mon
raisonnement est française vous n'êtes
pas musulmane ce n'est pas un pays ce
n'est pas la nationalité moi je suis je
ne suis pas je ne veux pas être
assimilée parce que l'assimilation et ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit la plupart des
économies 4 le disent c'est
l'assimilation dont vous parler parce
que parfois vous lancer des mots vous ne
savez même pas la signification
l'asim iliad l'assimilation c'est un
déséquilibre c'est à dire qu'on rejette
ses origines pour projet de la culture
est ce que vous pouvez me marie curie
rejeter sa culture polonaise
issu d'un bon wagon et a rejeté sa
culture italienne on a quelque chose en
commun d'avec eu peut-être bourdonne
tous les deux et moi je n'ai jamais
rejeté les lois de la république jeune
et jolie du zola j'adore zola je suis
musulmane musulmans musulmane pour
autant je porte le voile quand tu vais à
la mosquée ou quand quand les
circonstances le s'y prête et je
m'habille librement je suis aujourd'hui
infirmière cadre de santé coach sportif
sport santé je courais vous savez dans
les endroits où on me sort et le mileu
moi c ou c à paris dans les endroits
huppés quand je vais dans les banlieues
ou que je cours par exemple au maroc peu
importe je vois pas me sourit et ben
vous dites qu'on estime vous stigmatisez
revêt la femme se débat contre le siège
de toulouse s'il vous plaît à en finir
avec une chose arrive vite s'il vous
plaît parce qu'on allait vraiment au
bout parce que selon selon l'insee et
qui a un jour je voulais revenir sur sur
les solutions qu'apporte le
votre parti équivalent temps plein le
salaire moyen des hommes et des femmes
en france est supérieur à 480 euros
depuis 1972 a pas évolué qu'est ce que
vous faites pour les femmes dans ce cas
là qu'est ce que je fais avec plaisir je
vous promets pour vous à noter sur un
autre débat effectivement avec grand
plaisir sur ce débat sur l'égalité
salariale m'aimait pas là vraiment on
arrive au bout
merci en tout cas julien audy solutions
et pas simplement une stigmatisation des
banlieues dépend lieu durant le débat et
et autres ce soir ali marin thème merci
en tout cas vous invente participation
d'avoir joué le jeu merci à vous julien
odoul c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent demain à 20 heures pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative